is difficult to implement on the quantum
hardware because of large circuit depths.
Generally, calculations
can be more successful if you can,
first of all choose a reference state
and initial set of parameters
that create an ansatz state
close to the ground state.
And second, avoid unnecessary parameters.
These either introduce
greater circuit depth with no payoff
or create a larger parameter space
to search leading to plateaus
in the classical optimization.
What parameters are necessary is a problem
specific question
that requires careful thought.
Let's talk about where our guest of honor,
the Hamiltonian, is hiding in all of this.
As we learned in the previous section,
the Hamiltonian after qubit
mapping is represented as a sum of
weighted strings of Pauli operators.
Eventually, however,
we want to evaluate the expectation
value of our Hamiltonian on the ansatz
state produced by the variational form.
Luckily, quantum
mechanics is nice and linear
and this is what we'll use
to get the expectation value.
This is how it works.
We know the Hamiltonian is a weighted
sum of Paulis
because of linearity
the expectation value of the sum
is equal to the sum of the expectation
values of each Pauli string.
Well, this is great because as you already
know, measuring in the Pauli basis
is as simple as a rotation
of a standard measurement basis.
Instead of measuring the expectation value
on this huge Hamiltonian represented
as a sum, we first evaluate expectation
values of individual terms
and sum at the end
with corresponding weights.
This is why in many resources
you will see only single qubit rotations
after the ansatz.
This is what implements the Hamiltonian
in every execution of the circuit.
In the next video,
we'll explore what happens
during the classical optimization step.
I'll see you there.